we've talked a lot about convex lenses
so I thought I would do a quick video on
concave in lenses although there aren't
as many different combinations of what a
concave lens can do so just remember
concave has the word cave in it so I
always imagine that it's kind of caving
in Words caving in where it's a little
bit of an exaggerated drawing I think
you get the general idea this is a
concave lens right over here
and let me draw its principal axis so
this is its principal axis
it shouldn't curve at the beginning let
me just redraw it so that's its
principal axis and let me draw the two
focal points
let me draw one over here on the left
side and then let equal distance focal
point on the right side and I'm assuming
that the two surfaces are they're both
concave and they're symmetric over here
that's just assumption I'm making now
let's think about what's going to happen
if I put an object if I put an object
someplace on someplace on the left side
of this concave lens so I'll you could
put it let me just stick it anywhere so
let me stick it right over there
so if I do and like always we'll do our
two rays but with the concave lens what
I'm going to do I'm going to raise I'm
gonna do one that's parallel to the
principal axis and then I'm going to do
one that does not get diffracted so it
goes right through the center of the
lens and let's think of what would
happen so if we go parallel if we go
parallel to the principal axis this will
get diffracted away since it's coming in
parallel it'll get diffracted and we'll
get diffracted outwards so that it looks
like it's coming from this focus so
it'll get diffracted in a way so it
looks like it's coming from that focus
so it's getting diverged outward I guess
we could say and let me draw another let
me draw another point or another ray I
should say I'll do that in yellow and
this one's just going to go straight
through the center of the lens and not
get diffracted so it's just going to go
straight through the center of the lens
and not get diffracted so what will the
image be here well clearly these two
rays don't converge so we won't have a
real image
but they do both look like they're
diverging from someplace and they look
like they're diverging they look like
they're diverging from right over there
so whatever so look to an observer out
here if their eyeball is right over
there
it looked to an observer I could draw
their nose just make it clear what the
person who where where the eye is if
they look at from this side they're
going to see a virtual image of the
object right right over here just like
that so what you're actually going to
see is a virtual image of the object
that is not inverted and it's going to
be smaller it's going to look like it's
closer to the lens than it really is
anyway that's that's all there really is
to know I mean there's obviously there's
a lot you can know about anything but
but that's the general gist of a concave
lens